one other little funny element
Michael Cohen whatever you want to say
about him I find him to be a pretty
funny guy and in my interactions with
him including privately he's been on the
show a couple times I've been on his
show he's an all-around good guy and
he's genuinely very funny he appeared
yesterday on MSNBC with Ari melber
he said when asked what's going to
happen with Trump here he said Trump
Trump's going to fill his diaper and he
says it completely seriously this is
nothing other than a comedic interlude
listen to people we build knowledge I
can't speak to his mental personal
process but he is going to learn in a
different way through the primary
experience and he entertains the
prospect
that he could be convicted and he could
lose his appeals and he could at the end
of that line potentially he's legally
Presumed Innocent he could end up
in prison
based on your long years of service with
him how will he process that yeah very
poorly
um you know as I like to call him
sometimes in my tweets diaper Donald
we'll be filling up that diaper because
he this is not something that Donald is
capable of either understanding or
contending with he as you stated
accurately he believes he could control
every situation this is not a situation
that he has any control over right and
that's making him sick to his stomach
yeah and I do think that that's a really
interesting thing more generally with
narcissists and we've talked about this
before
narcissists believe
among other things that they can
convince anyone that they're the
smartest and slickest and most clever in
the room and that they can lie and
nobody notices and this is why with the
Mueller probe Trump wanted to testify to
be to sit down for questioning uh to be
deposed
and his lawyers didn't let him because
Trump thinks I'll just sit down with
them I'll be able to convince them that
I'm telling the truth that they they
won't know I'll be lying that is a
really common trait of narcissists
Michael Cohen knows it it's going to be
a wild 48 hours and I'm glad you're with
us for it